I want to give you a single language
pattern change that you can do to
increase how much people believe what
you say and it's by using the word but
not the way you think two statements
that go on either side of but you have
something good and something bad
typically because but shows that there's
a difference between the two most people
say good statement but bad but the
beautiful thing is with persuasion you
can actually flip it and so you put the
negative stuff first you say hey our
program's really hard it's really long
it's honestly very complicated but it
works better than anything you've ever
tried before